das ist die fragenlotterie mit fiesen
fragen und ganz harmlosen fragen
harmlose fragen sind die grünen fiesen
fragen rot du kannst dir aussuchen was du
willst du musst die
fragen nicht beantworten du kannst dich entscheiden okay dann sind die
fiesen fragen die grünen nein nein
nein die  rote auf diesem oh die roten
sind böse
okay kann ich dich auch um eins bitten ja du kannst
hey hast du diese gemacht entschuldigung kannst
du diese weihnachten machen was dich
einzigartig macht gut ich habe ein sehr seltsames leben
aber unsere leben sind seltsam mein leben  ist
einzigartig, weil ich meinen Lebensunterhalt mit meiner Lieblingsbeschäftigung machen kann
und es klingt so
kitschig, wenn ich es sage, wenn ich es so sage
, aber es ist die Wahrheit und es ist
erstaunlich, ich hoffe, das wird lange so
bleiben, ja, ich kann nicht  genug bekommen okay also noch zwei oder
drei du kannst dich blind entscheiden du willst nur
früh morgens aufwachen
ja warum hast du immer an
dich geglaubt ich habe nicht immer an
mich
geglaubt  Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand das nicht sagen kann
Ich denke, dass es ein so langer Prozess ist, herauszufinden, wer Sie sind und wer Sie sein
möchten, dass
Sie sowohl als
Songwriter als auch als Person wissen, wann die
Momente, in denen Sie dachten, mmm, ist
es in dieser Richtung richtig,
denke ich, ich habe  diese Momente die ganze
Zeit, ja, es war wirklich wichtig für mich
nach dieser wirklich langen Tour, auf der ich war
, in eine andere Stadt zu gehen,
um mich zu isolieren, um zu schreiben, aber auch um
über diese Dinge nachzudenken, denn wenn
du so lebst, wie ich bin, bist du es.  Ich
rede ständig darüber, wo du warst,
als du dein letztes Album gemacht hast, egal ob
das zwei Monate oder zwei Jahre her ist, und
es ist wichtig, einfach innezuhalten und zu überlegen, ob
ich das mache, weil ich es will oder
weil alle es
erwarten oder weil du es weißt  und es ist einfach
immer das, was ich getan habe, und es war auch
für mich als Person wichtig, wissen Sie
, wer ich bin, wenn niemand
etwas erwartet, also denke ich manchmal, dass
es für alle Menschen wichtig ist, dass
jeder diese hat und versucht, einige
Auszeiten zu haben  in dem  In deinem Leben hast du mir gesagt, dass du
manchmal nicht weißt, was du willst
und was sie jemals von dir wollen, der
Plattenfirma oder dem Publikum oder
was dein Wunsch ist und was der Wunsch der
anderen ist, was andere Wünsche der anderen
gut wir  Versuchen Sie, in unserer Zusammenarbeit sehr offen zu
sein, aber natürlich
wollen wir andere Dinge, wissen Sie, für mich liegt
mein Hauptaugenmerk darauf, mich als
Songwriter weiterzuentwickeln und dieses
verrückte Leben zu führen und auch ein Privatleben zu haben,
etwas, das nur für mich ist
Die Stille kommt mit solchen Auszeiten,
während die
Plattenfirma vielleicht möchte, dass ich einfach
weitermache und weitermache und
für mich ist die Musik ein großer Teil
meines Lebens für so viele andere Menschen und
gerade jetzt  Musik ist meine Musik ist ein
Geschäft und es ist sehr wichtig für mich,
nicht zu viel darüber nachzudenken,
ja, es ist sehr wichtig, dass ich mich darauf konzentrieren muss,
was meine Ziele sind, okay, also habe ich die letzte Frage hinterlassen.
Metin, okay, es ist okay, war dein Rockstar-
Leben zu stressig  oder warum  Hast du
deinen Musikstil geändert? Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich meinen Musikstil geändert habe. Ich denke, wo
ich als Künstler gerade stehe, ist es sehr
logisch. Ja, es ist ein
sehr organischer Weg, von wo ich
als Songwriter angefangen habe  Ich schreibe
jetzt seit 15 Jahren Songs und die
Geschichten, die ich erzählen möchte, werden
sich von Album zu Album ändern. Wenn
ich eine Geschichte geschrieben habe, lege ich fest, dass sie
zu einem Song gehört, lege ich sie in eine Schachtel
und dann mache ich weiter, aber als Songwriter,
aber als Performer war m2m eine andere
Art von Musik oder nicht, und nun, das war
anders, aber ich denke, das lag hauptsächlich
daran, dass ich so viel jünger war, du kennst
meinen Geschmack und meine Fähigkeiten und alles,
ja ich  liebte, was wir
damals gemacht haben, und ich bin immer noch stolz auf so viele
dieser Songs, ich glaube, wir waren wirklich, wir haben
genau das gemacht, was wir wollten, und
das gelernt zu haben, und es fällt
mir jetzt auch leichter, ein bisschen zu sein
entspannter, wenn ich Alben veröffentliche, weil ich das
weiß, solange ich
hundertprozentig s bin  Klar, wenn ich präsentiere
und im Moment ist das, was ich präsentieren möchte
, dann kann ich in fünf
oder fünfzig Jahren darauf zurückblicken und weiß
, egal wie ich das bewerte, was ich
komponiert habe, du weißt im Nachhinein, okay,
so ein Grün  eins zum schluss okay
oh warum bist du so schön dein vater
deine mutter deine großmutter weil
ich schöne menschen in meinem leben habe ja ja
okay du bist auch schön
oh vielen dank du bist ein bisschen
schöner als ich
danke für die  Kompliment,
danke, danke, dass
du hergekommen bist, vielen Dank, vielen Dank